Sam has just traveled through time-space
and logic and finds himself fully alive
and more importantly rich again this joy
is only dimmed by the fact that it can't
move at all
this is when he shows up death are you
ok can you hear me blink twice if yes oh
cool you're alive
everything is fine right so this here is
the deal on this all your body functions
are manuals so you kinda have to do
stuff on purpose
you're turning kind of blue might wanna
consider reading
all right bitching you're blinking and
breathing that's that's bitching so
right goes to the right for a day and
I'll let you live normally for the rest
of your life if you somehow die within
the next 24 hours I'll take your shreds
and you'll be that forever I'll be over
there doing kick flips if you need me
once again Sam has to make an effort to
get up this time he has to focus on his
spine
and once again he has to remind himself
how to walk
oh by the way dude it's Friday morning
so you're getting late for work Sam
panics he doesn't do much at work but
his father is still very strict about
him showing up on time it has to do with
morale of the rest of his company
Sam tries out a strange maneuver by
stepping with the same leg twice he has
to use his opposite leg to get up again
Sam holds on to that toothbrush like his
life depends on it
Sam brushes his teeth horribly with
clean teeth Sam is ready to smile Sam is
dumb enough to breathe in with his mouth
full of water he has to cough Sam tries
to take a leak
Sam takes a leak everywhere including
but not limited to in your impressing no
one sound
Sam tries to take a shower it looks more
like a madness that is trying to explain
to someone how a bicycle works
next on the list is putting uncle out
Sam can open doors now clever boy you're
impressing no one Santa sees water what
will he wear today he picks a pair of
blue jeans the ugly ones
Sam successfully puts on his pass
feeling more accomplished than ever he
proceeds to find a jacket only the best
one will do
Sam has some trouble with his posture
and has to focus on his spine fully
loaded Sam is ready for the day PS he is
not
he puts on his shoes
living the dream of having on shoes Sam
walks down two stairs with great
precision
flappy rooster is Sam's favorite game
there's no time for playing with flappy
roosters right now though
oh hey dude you should probably eat
something
there is a note saying sent over a maid
to make you breakfast don't forget to
chew love mum your spine Sam it matters
you're impressing no one Sam
Sam decides to fly herself on some
coffee drinking
Sam's coffee is so hot he blows on it
before taking a sip
out of cups out of hope it finally makes
it out the front door
beaten terrified it was like that when I
got here bro dude you might want to get
that thing fixed
ah that doesn't look right